toxic masculinity is one of the most  evil terms I've ever heard you're  literally shaming young boys for just  being themselves what's regarded as  toxic masculinity is being strong being  competitive being aggressive well these  are actually really amazing traits these  are necessary traits in order to conquer  the world and become successful what  they're doing is they're shaming them  for being their natural self suppressing  them so that they don't grow up to be  conquerors of the world strong powerful  because when they are strong and  powerful then they can fight the Tyranny  easily there's no such thing as toxic  masculinity there's just toxic people